what's the deal with everything peanuts
peanuts Chris Rock and Louis C.K two of
the most famous comedians of our time
both just made history with their live
shows only 33 days apart Chris Rock
returning from the slap Louis CK
returning to Madison Square Garden two
legends took the stage with the whole
world watching live and now just one
question remains on everyone's mind who
did it better and who better to answer
that question than the 198 000 Die Hard
comedy fans who are subscribed to joke
world after 48 Hours the results were in
and honestly a bit surprising but before
we reveal who won let's quickly recap
what went down at each show Louis CK
back at the Garden streamed live on
January 31st from Louis CK's website and
cost 25 bucks to watch it was a huge
deal for Louis CK to return to Madison
Square Garden after years away and a
show has been described by those in
attendance as being quote really [__]
cool how's the MSG live it was really
[__] cool Chris Rock's elective
outrage streamed live on March 4th
directly on Netflix it was the first
live stream in Netflix history there was
a pre and post game show and this was
the first time Chris Rock publicly
addressed the Will Smith Oscar slap oh
wow not only did Rapport receive a ton
of votes but many comedy fans wanted to
share some insights on their experiences
watching both of these streams I'm not
Ben Avery said CK hands down Flawless
great openers rocks openers just stroked
ego and hyped the moment more than
delivered real laughter messing up the
closer was the only memorable moment and
really took the steam out of the moment
I left three times at most couldn't have
been more excited I let several friends
know it was happening that night with
all the hype I've been hearing it was a
major letdown released as a regular
special it would have been fine but
nothing groundbreaking in the live
version he says Jada didn't want me to
host the Oscars because her husband
wasn't nominated for emancipation yeah
oh he meant to say concussion he meant
to say concussion the punch line is then
concussion later so he even says in the
special he goes he goes ah [__] up the
joke kooky face said two different
styles and points in their lives when it
comes to Art yes comedy these questions
seem stupid or so limited it's like
what's the best care bear like what the
[__] maybe you think it's Grumpy Bear
because you can relate to him sometimes
or Good Luck Bear because he comes
correct on the humble but you sleep on
the sunshine bear who brings the fire
and Good Vibes who knows there ain't no
real answer son what Infinity love said
Louis CK special was amazing top to
bottom a solid special that ramped up
Chris Rock's special was important his
slapback was epic and the best part of
the show I loved both for different
reasons I'm excited to watch the new
live Trend hopefully it continues in the
way comedy is experience evolves there
were many more comments just like this
from people who enjoyed both shows but
the question Still Remains who did it
better after two whole days of waiting
the results are finally in we asked 198
000 comedy fans who had the better live
stream Chris Rock's elective outrage or
Louis CK back to the Garden the vote was
split 62-38 with Louis CK back to the
Garden coming out on top these results
really just show how great of a comedian
Louis CK is he won this poll by a
considerable margin and when you really
think about it Louis didn't have nearly
the same amount of resources to pull
this off he had to pay for everything
stream off his own website and do all of
his own promotion Chris Rock on the
other hand was the exact opposite still
riding the viral wave of the slap and
with Netflix's whole advertising team
behind him not to say selective outrage
wasn't great because it was this is just
more to give extra perspective into why
what Louis did was so impressive it's
definitely going to be very interesting
to see if live specials become a trend
in comedy moving forward but either way
we'll have you covered right here at
joke world with all the comedy news
related to all of your favorite
comedians so if you haven't already
joined this community of like-minded
Comedy fans consider this your official
invitation into the club all you have to
do to officially join is click the
Subscribe button kiss your mouse and
then click the Subscribe button that's
actually how you join the club you can't
just click it you have to lick and kiss
your mouse and then click subscribe and
then you're in the joke World Club the
best community of Comedy fans anywhere
on the internet and the fastest growing
they say that they say that too
thank you
[Music]